[Music]
Jonathan is with us in Lexington hey
Jonathan welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
thank you Dave and Merry Christmas
merry Christmas to you how can I help so
a few months after I was born my mom
took out a whole life policy on me and
every year has been paying it since I'm
27 now good
and me and my wife we've got about 92
thousand dollars in consumer debt Fonuts
combined income of about 90 we've we've
made some mistakes you know my question
for you is can I approach my mom asked
her to cash out that whole life policy
which it says the
total cash value is about 7,300 yeah and
I guess after taxes apply that to our
debt though there won't be in taxes the
because your basis and a whole life
policy is what you've paid into it and
she's paid a lot more than 7,300 others
into this so it'll be a loss it won't be
a gain she's gonna argue with you
because she thinks she has saved money
wisely and while she is not right okay
my wife we I have a term life insurance
policy we've got to kind of maxed out
through her employer but it's still not
enough for the 10 to 12 yah I'm sorry
income you need to get that I need to
get the proper amount of term insurance
in place and then you need to catch this
out now are you not in control of the
policy is she not already turn it over
here 27 years old
I'm the direct beneficiary but she's
still the payer okay who's the owner I
am okay if you're the owner you can cash
it out any time you want you've just got
to deal with the relationship aspects of
this though meaning you're gonna have to
sit down with her and go mom I'm not
wasting this money we're working a plan
to get out of debt thank you for
thinking of me all these years and we're
gonna move forward without this policy
and I just I want to honor your intent
and your intent was to make us
prosperous and we are on our way to
doing that because we're paying off this
$90,000 and
how much of those cars one hits ninth
nineteen but cars worth about ten enjoy
so it's not cars what is the student
loans got twenty wanted credit cards
that nineteen in a car and then 36 in
student loans that's out and ten
thousand in a new HVAC unit oh okay yeah
so are you through borrowing yes we we
went to Financial Peace University a few
months ago graduates from that and good
yeah well just walk her through that as
I hope you can without hurting her
feelings because she's probably from an
emotional standpoint very invested in
this policy she is also invested without
a doubt money in this policy and so but
she's put more than seventy three
hundred dollars into it which shows you
how bad these things suck the fact that
she's gonna get zero you're gonna get
you know your M no gain the thing didn't
even make as much as you put into it
which is just ridiculous that shows
they're just horrible that's just never
buy cash by your insurance people never
never never never not for your little
kids not for your grandma never buy
insurance as an investment component to
it you're always these never and always
are big and complete words never buy it
you're always better off investing any
where else by term life insurance that's
all you're doing
inexpensive ten to twelve times your
income fifteen to twenty year level term
life insurance click Zander insurance
get a quick easy quote it's it's the
cost of a dadgum pizza and then do and
it costs about one-twentieth about five
percent of what cash value insurance
costs if that poor lady that's
we lady his mommy had put the same
amount of money in a mutual fund he
would have seventy three thousand
dollars right now instead of seventy
three hundred dollars or more probably
more I don't know the premium amount but
I'm just saying that's how the case
studies will work out when you run the
actual compound interest and so she put
more than seventy three hundred dollars
into the policy you know what that means
she would have been better off putting
the money in a cookie jar she would have
ended up with more he's gonna get out
less than she has put in you understand
that I mean if that doesn't suck I don't
know what does this is a bad idea boys
and girls and yet people still buy
Gerber life insurance policies I mean
buy baby food from the same people you
buy life insurance investment products
from that should have been a hint you
know really that should have told you
right there that you had a problem no no
no no sweet lady well-intentioned got
screwed by the insurance industry again
there it is why wasn't unclear